Film Courage: What is your advice for actors
or comics who are going up against the same
people time and again [in auditions].
I know of a couple of people who have the
same names on IMDB and it’s been competitive
when they see each other…it’s awkward.
Jonathan Mangum, Actor/Comedian/Announcer
for the game show Let's Make a Deal: I mean…it’s
competitive if you go into an audition thinking
‘the best person is going to get the job’
and that is never the case.
The best person is never the one that gets
the job.
It’s all about what do they need?
What type do they need?
Do they need someone who is this tall?
Does it have to look like the kid they have
already hired?
Is this guy the friend of the producer?
I mean there are so many variables that it
is never a meritocracy in auditions (ever)
in my 25 years of doing it.
There is a level.
You need to be great to get up into that to
be picked from but there is no “The Best.”
And as long as you realize there is no “The
Best,” then you can feel less competitive
with people you see all the time.
Film Courage: Was it a learning experience,
coming to peace with that?
Jonathan: Yes, it took a long time because
you’re just like “Ahhh?
They were better than me and got the part.”
It’s like “No.
They may have been better than you but that’s
not why they got the part,” there are so
many reasons that you will never know and
no one calls you and says “Hey, that guy
reminded the producer of his best friend from
high school so they hired him.”
I mean there are so many different variables
it’s ridiculous.
You just go in, do your best, bring what you
bring, your special take on it and then once
you’re done with that, it’s out of your
control.